nikola bonjour heureux de vous retrouver
dans la matinale de rtl france bonjour
olivier mais aussi alors ce matin un
petit tour d'horizon à des régionales
caisse joue-t-il pour ces élections le
mois prochain nicolas alors je ne sais
pas voulu ville et moi je me passionne
pour ces élections régionales qui
ressemble à une grosse course à
l'échalote politique il ya un tour de
france des ténors deux parties petit
rappel les régionales ont lieu chaque
six ans et respecte un scrutin de liste
proportionnelle de tous on y lit un
conseiller régional qui élire un
président du conseil régional et ça sera
le 20 et le 27 juin prochain on est
vraiment impatient
il faut rappeler que c'est françois
hollande qui a redécoupé les régions
françaises en 2014 comme on le fait avec
une grosse cote de boeuf pour appliquer
la réforme territoriale et on est passé
de 13 à 22 régions
alors il y avait deux objectifs olivia
cette réforme griffonnée sur un coin de
table temps françois l'on ne voulait pas
froisser certains barons locaux
le premier objectif était de faire des
économies
et bien c'est loupé la cour des comptes
triste objectif dans un rapport de 2019
en pointant une augmentation de 50
millions d'euros annuels et le gène jeu
objectif moins avouables calquer
l'administration territoriale française
hollander allemand enfin être mieux
dissous dans le maelström européen
enfin bon passons tout ce petit monde à
prod et sa liste 17 mai dernier dans la
joie et la bonne humeur
i la grande cavalcade électorale peut
commencer avec un air deux
présidentielles et déjà son lot de
boulettes olivier alors comment les
portes les parties aborde-t-il cette
dernière ligne droite de campagne une
campagne à un pitbull s'agit d'aller sur
le terrain et en sortir des qg
politiques parisiens pour aller taper
sur le cul des vaches arpenter les
marchés et se mettre à portée
d'engueulades tout en se farcissant les
militants sur place
alors on prend des trains des avions
pour allier les quatre coins du
territoire et soutenir le candidat
régional
le charismatique christian jacob par
exemple s'est lancé ces déplacés pardon
dans le gard pour soutenir
aurélien pradié en occitanie alors tout
cet aéropage est allé flatter les
agriculteurs les indépendants et les
entreprises locales et on a vu même
aurélien pradié porté à bout de bras un
agneau face caméra après avoir traîné le
boss des républicains christian jacob en
camargue voir un élevage de taureaux
puis on l'a vue entamée chose curieuse
étrange un dialogue heures qu'un homard
dans une poissonnerie locale
une voie est une voix olivier et il ne
faut pas ménagé sa peine et son audace
alors dans ces campagnes il est toujours
question de proximité vous savez le
terrain de territoire pour aller au
contact des français est serré beaucoup
beaucoup de paluches dans les marchés
parce que ça fait peuple paraît-il mais
malgré le crash annoncé les républicains
il une petite lueur d'espoir du côté des
hauts de france carla rem est en train
de s'embourber dans les champs de
betteraves politique et le mouvement
présidentiel a donc décidé de lancer une
grande opération anti et rennes et
surtout surtout anti xavier bertrand
alors tout le monde fait route vers le
nord
ce n'est plus les taxis de la marne mais
les berlines hysteria halle du pas de
calais eu eric dupond moretti s'est
retroussé les manches et à dégrafer ses
boutons de manchette
agnès pannier rue nashik quant à elle a
carrément élu domicile à lens c'est plus
tranquille et moins de techno et même si
ce déménagement est en train de
déclencher une vive polémique
et puis pour bercy vous savez olivier le
travail télétravail ce n'est pas un
problème
et concernant la fermeture de
bridgestone à béthune les 8 163 en place
mais c'est oublier agnès pannier rue
nash et n'est pas rancunière parce
qu'elle est comme ça agnès cette
invasion de ministres dans les hauts de
france a pour but de dégommer le soldat
bertrand qui pourraient être l'an
prochain le candidat le moins mauvais
des républicains alors effectivement
être pour être plus politiquement
correct il faudrait dire naturelles ou
de rassemblement alors du côté du ps les
marécages sont profonds et le fonds
n'est jamais atteint la polémique on
trouve autour d'audrey pulvar et de
liste en île de france a lancé la
campagne sans compter sur une île
étrange avec gérald darmanin dans ce je
t'aime moi non plus résultat 10 %
d'intentions de vote selon il faut que
chacun aurait pu voir un véritable monde
ici pour finir en france l'as le pead
finalement semble en bien mauvaise
posture au liquide en plus d'être un
plan social en point c'est aussi un plan
social politique qui ne pourra pas se
délient à l'étranger il a qu'à voir
laure leroy ta crème catalane électorale
en réalité à bâillonner socialiste
semble avoir tourné et du populaire el
marine le pen espère sortir libre
marrons du feu
il a candidats traçantes devenir
superman qui sont partis du populeux et
17 ans selon olivier
alors nicolas les français selon vous
faut-il se mobiliser pour ces élections
bien les français se sont abstenus
massivement pour les municipales l'esat
déjà entrevoir les relents d'une
insurrection silencieuse il lorsqu'on
voit le cirque électoral pour nous
rejoue à chaque élection on peut parier
que les bureaux de vote éviteront la
submersion des lecteurs les 20 et 27
juin prochains le héros l'eire 0 pardon
devrait être badens et l'isoloir et pas
de kloster en vue cette élection en
réalité d'une nouvelle fois une guerre
ridicule deroite les nationaux et deux
barons locaux bras dessus bras dessous
qui incarne le naufrage de notre classe
politique alors que ce pays vit des
heures sombres dans tous les domaines et
en ce début de matinée est mon cher
olivier je pense à pierre desproges qui
disait je cite à par la droite il n'y a
rien au monde que je méprise autant que
la gauche
faudrait pas que les français se disent
la même chose merci beaucoup nicolas
nicolas vidal votre édito à retrouver
bien évidemment sur les réseaux sociaux
et quant à nous on se retrouve jeudi
prochain